so Jeff Bezos goes in front of this
audience and there's probably more than
10,000 people in the stadium and go what
his day to look like and says something
like day two is stasis followed by
irrelevance followed by slow painful
decline followed by death for the whole
company and he looks out and he goes and
that's why it's always day one
Alex Kantrowitz in the building how you
doing one I'm doing great really glad to
be on with you Chris thanks for having
me today it's timely for me to have
someone that reports on tech given that
an hour ago from when we're recording
this Elon Musk just tweeted Tesla stock
price is too high
IMO and they're now down 11% that's
right Chris but to be honest anytime you
we have recorded this podcast whether it
was today a couple weeks ago or a few
weeks from now
Elon would definitely tweet something
absolutely ridiculous that would send
his company in some sort of tailspin so
it's not very surprising that he tried
to tank his stack about five minutes
before we hopped on here so Yvonne's
just gonna keep being Elon that's just
how he does things heal undid an Elon
didn't he yes he did yes he did when and
did ladies his twitter is definitely fun
to follow I mean you just just mostly
because of the unpredictability about it
like he's got this valuable thing and
Tesla and he keeps playing with its
future every time he hits that tweet
button like for him especially maybe you
should just you know have someone where
he has to read the tweets aloud and then
they type it into the box and then they
send it and that might prevent some of
this stuff from happening but it doesn't
seem like he's really interested in that
so no yeah I think a guardian of his
Twitter you know like you get when
you've got you carry on you kids aren't
allowed to use the iPad for more than an
hour a day or whatever you know I look
at this this this tweets got the wood
stock price in it this means that it
needs to go through five layers you
don't want to certain that but until
until he does his Twitter accounts gonna
be a lot of fun to watch and you're
right you're right as well despite the
fact he's done that today whenever this
gets published whenever this episode
goes live you know they're probably done
something that day too so just go and
have a look at Elan musk of Twitter
right now and see what he's done I'd
love to kind don't have the same
reaction yeah anyway we're not talking
about Elon Musk today we're talking
about your new book always day one why
is it called
always day one yeah it's a great
question so I so Jeff Bezos gets in
front of Amazon's
employees a couple years ago and he's
got this
card with him and it's at the end of
this All Hands meeting and it says it's
a question submitted from one of his
employees and it says what does date to
look like this is sort of not the thing
that you want to ask Jeff Bezos because
he's been preaching this always day wad
mentality inside Amazon and I always
thought that all this day one just sort
of meant you don't want to work as hard
as you possibly can you work nights you
work weekends you work holidays and if
you take your foot off the gas pedal
you're done and so Jeff Bezos goes in
front of this audience and there's
tendon I mean yeah probably more than
ten thousand people in the stadium in
Seattle and go what his day to look like
and he says something like day two is
stasis followed by irrelevance followed
by slow painful decline followed by
death for the whole company and he looks
out and he goes and that's why it's
always day one and you know I saw this
clip when I was getting deep into my
reporting on Amazon and my first view of
it was oh he is doing this hustle porn
thing work so hard you know work eighty
ninety hours otherwise you're out of
Amazon and if that was the case I
definitely would have had it would not
have had it as the title of the book
because I you know I do think that it's
important to work hard but I'm kind of
skeptical of these people let's say you
need to work 100 hours a week or you're
not gonna make it I think it's possible
to have a healthy work-life balance and
still do okay
what I found out that always day one
meets inside Amazon is that they're
always inventing the next business line
without any regard for what what they
have today and what they had in the past
so for them it's about reinvention it's
about let's keep building new products
we won't sit on our flagship products
and wait for them to take us you know
all the way because you know right now
it's just impossible to do that in the
1920s the average company would sit on
the 14th of fortune 500 for 67 years
today it's 15 years so that's why Amazon
and mint and the rest of the tech
giant's live in this always day one
mentality they're constantly reinventing
because they know if they get to
Prussia's about the present and the past
they're going to miss the future so
there's this mentality that they have to
continually be inventing themselves into
the future or else they're done and
there's a culture that underpins it's
not enough to
have this mentality and say we want to
live in day one and just go about your
business as a traditional company what
they've done the real ingenuity inside
these companies is building the culture
technology and process that's allowed
them to keep reinventing and that's
helped them stay on top how did you get
such access to all of these companies
like who you why why should you be the
person that's able to peer into the most
exciting biggest most innovative
companies on the planet you know that is
a great question and sometimes I've been
a bit surprised but I will say that I'm
a tech reporter here in Silicon Valley
live in San Francisco so I've spent the
last five years here and I was reporting
on tech in New York before that and so I
have spent a lot of time meeting with
these companies in Silicon Valley and my
reporting has has been out there people
people recognize it so I think there
might have been a sense that this book
was gonna have an impact and then one
thing that I have that most tech
reporters don't is a background in
industrial and labor relations meaning
that I've studied the nature of work and
organizational behavior Human Resources
how companies are run how people are
motivated and I've brought that with me
here so by having that background and
then looking at the tech companies and
saying I want to write a book about how
they how they work and what it means for
the future of the way that we work and
the way we lead companies to me that
must have resonated yeah I think so as
opposed to I imagine some tech report is
most armchair philosophize about how the
world might be as opposed to perhaps
someone like yourself who's got more
real-world experience of what actually
happens within these companies what a
culture like this means to the people
who live it and breathe it and work it
that's right yeah and I also worked in
sales and marketing for three years
before becoming a reporter so I have an
idea of how like companies that sell
products work so that's potentially that
you know that that background helps but
yeah my main philosophy as a reporter is
don't get lost in narratives you know
don't try to make someone look good or
try to make someone look bad just tell
the truth and you know I think that um I
think that's that's helped me out in my
career for sure that's awesome so high
level what's what's the book you've
covering different companies and looking
at different
yes so it's all about how they put this
always day one mentality into action
inside their companies and so they've
done this into in well actually really
three ways one is have the mentality
right if you have the mentality that
you're gonna try to milk your asset your
flagship business and not worry about
building another business you're gonna
be you're gonna be screwed so they have
the mentality the second thing is they
do they do is they view work differently
than most of us do right so I think that
we need a separate work the work we do
into two buckets one is ideal work
that's anything that's involved in
coming up with new ideas and bringing it
to life and the other is execution work
you know and that's anything that's
involved in supporting the existing
products that you have so we've gone
through three major transfer me to major
transformations but three eras in our
work life since the factory era you know
people forget the factory was only a
hundred years ago that was dominating
our economy hundred years ago human
existence is much longer than 100 years
so we've had radical transformations in
the way that we work in just a century
and our systems like our cultural
systems or leadership systems are always
a little bit slow to catch up and they
certainly have in this point so let's
start with the factory in the industrial
era almost all the work that we did was
execution work there would be like one
little bit of ideal work which came from
like the owner of the factory right who
said let's make widgets and what do they
hire employees to do all execution work
just being in the factory making widgets
okay then in the middle of the 1900s we
transitioned to what's called the
knowledge economy which all of a sudden
employee ideas actually mattered but
because we were so processed heavy we
would have a teeny tiny bit of our time
and this is what exists in most
companies now but teeny tiny bit of our
time on idea work and still most of it
was on execution work now we weren't
pushing buttons and hitting levers like
we were in the factory but we were doing
similar work that that it wasn't really
involved in creating anything new so
that could be anything from moving
numbers from one spreadsheet to another
or putting the same invoice into to buy
at the same product at the same amount
every week or writing the same letters
to the same people every week I mean
anyone who's been in a job knows this
right and because there's been there was
so much execution work
the knowledge economy our ideas really
haven't been taken into consideration by
management so you know I think that
anyone who's you know people come into
companies they're creative and they're
filled with energy and they want to
change the way the company works and
they see all this opportunity because
all this opportunity is there and they
know we can do this and launch this
product line and we can change this
process and hey we'll have you thought
about connecting these two groups and
that energy usually lasts for the first
six months or so until they're told
actually you know we don't really you're
not really here for your ideas you hear
just to like do this one little task and
doesn't matter how much you can
contribute to making this company better
we're not actually really concerned with
it that's the message that gets sent
because anyone who's brought these ideas
inside the company knows generally
people say oh you know not really time
for that or you know you were hired to
do this why are you saying that and
that's a factor of the fact that we're
living in this execution work economy
because even in the knowledge economy
most companies don't have the capability
to take those employee ideas and turn
them into into life because they are
spending all of their time supporting
their existing products ok so this
brings me into what the tech giants do
what they've done is use technology
process automation and process
optimization to take the amount of
execution work they have in their
companies down and then make room for
ideal work and then once they have their
employees you know thinking of new ideas
and having permission to actually come
up with ideas because that's a big part
of it they build system to take those
ideas to decision-makers and bring them
to reality and everyone's saying why are
Amazon Apple Facebook Google Microsoft
so strong you know what are they doing
that's illegal and they definitely have
some nefarious behavior but to me the
most important thing is culture
it starts with culture it begins with
taking down execution work move for
ideal work building the systems to turn
those ideas into life and that's why
they're lapping the economy more than
anything is just not something anyone
talks about and I think if the rest of
us start paying attention to these
systems we have a much better chance of
competing in their world competing with
them carving your own carving out our
own niches to be able to make this
happen today and and that's sort of that
the point of the book is I I said enough
of this right I want to get a second
choice yeah teach me the secret sauce
that's right
so I was just like yeah enough of this
I'm in Silicon Valley might as well let
people know what's going on so the rest
of us can start to come and and you know
act the way they do in our own companies
and you know start to make some progress
in evening this economy out yeah it's
fascinating that the the friction of
taking idea from in someone's head to
the market is one of the major barriers
that people need to get over so you got
to have the capacity within the company
operationally innovatively in order to
be able to deliver that right but then
you also need to give have the talent
and the time for that talent to come up
with the right amount of ideas and then
probably iterate on them and get rid of
the bad ones and get rid of the bad ones
and get rid of the bad ones and then
finally you come up with this super
left-field thing and that's how you end
up with companies you know going through
the book it's mad all of the different
stuff specifically Amazon but all of the
companies have their fingers in little
different pies like E and you think oh
why why are they doesn't really seem to
make so much sense it's not part of
their core business but then you
actually realize when you're constantly
innovating and iterating on these
different things you these ideas are
going to come to the forefront and
you're the person that's able to bring
it to the market it's um it's mud that's
right in it sounds so simple right give
people more time for ideas and bring
them to life it's actually fairly
complex and that's what these companies
do so well and I can give you an example
if you're interested
so you mentioned Amazon Amazon to me
does this in the in the most wild way
that I had no idea about and actually
hasn't really been reported about too
much and I got to see it firsthand when
I was out in Seattle spent a good chunk
of two summers in Seattle hanging out
reporting on Amazon and cat sitting my
friend mother's cat lady the cat who's
uh was a good friend of the process and
you know really yeah it was fun lady
really kept me kept me going and you
know those days and know many people in
Seattle so it was nice to have that cat
friend in that time but I will say that
okay so Amazon so one of the things I
really wanted to know is how does Amazon
use automation not just in the factories
and the were sorry the warehouses
but in their headquarters as well
because I heard some rumblings that like
hey people are getting their jobs
automated and and Amazon's headquarters
and you don't hear that too often so
what I found out is that they have a
program called hands off the wheel and
hands off the wheel automates a lot of
the traditional retail tasks for
employees and Amazon's retail division
so I'll explain so typically when you
your company like Amazon you have these
people called vendor managers and vendor
managers are on the phone all day with
with suppliers saying we need this many
units and this these many fulfillment
centers at this time at this price so
you got a vendor manager that on the
phone Procter and Gamble and it say we
want detergent give us like X number of
units of detergent you know in these
locations
we wanted at like 650 a unit and we want
it there you know in installments of
every other week or something like that
and Amazon built an army of people who
were working with vendor men working
with vendors to stock their fulfillment
centers and all of a sudden in the mid
2010 Amazon was like wait a second we
have all this data that shows us what
people want actually our data probably
knows better than the vendor managers
what they want because it's precise and
what if we decide that we could have our
machine learning team work on this and
they figure out how to use computers to
do all this stuff instead of people and
that's what they did they started a
project that was called Project Yoda
which is instead of the vendor managers
doing this they would use the force when
the force being machine learning right
and yeah it's a funny name and you know
it's obviously like when you got nerds
running the company you're gonna get
good jokes like nuts if Star Wars
references you that's right yeah and
then they moved so they worked on this a
bit they work they moved moved it
further the program changed from project
Yoda to hands off the wheel essentially
taking telling their vendor managers
you've been driving the car now we're
gonna let the machine learning do it on
its own and a good portion of tasks
inside Amazon right now are all being
handled by a machine learning so things
like ordering inventory management even
when a vendor wants to negotiate with
Amazon they instead of picking up the
phone now start to like suggest prices
in a computer portal and Amazon says
yeah okay cool or no that's
all being done by machine learning today
I mean in some some cases there's human
intervention but very little and
actually just sighting like a figure to
talk about the magnitude one of Amazon's
machine learning a head said that letter
managers used to go used to be able to
handle 1000 projects products now they
can handle somewhere around a hundred
thousand he later clarified saying is
just ballparking it's not really but
come on like that's that must be the you
know in the range of the type of man
orders of magnitude more they're able to
handle okay so what happens now when all
these tests are being taken over by
machine learning a dumb company would
say great let's fire the vendor manage
but that's not what happens inside
Amazon so these vendor managers are now
all on product and program manager jobs
where they're basically professional
inventors inside the company working the
shepherd new ideas along and they have a
process inside Amazon called this six
pager
where instead of starting projects with
a PowerPoint they start at where you
write everything down in six pages
single-spaced 11 point font no pictures
and it's supposed to be like okay you're
gonna write the entire way that the
project is going to look like and we can
get that to a decision maker pretty
quickly and doesn't matter which level
you're in right just a couple of
forwards can get that thing to Bezos or
his top lieutenants so that's the system
to get ideas to decision makers okay
I'll just finish with a example to bring
this all to life there's a guy named
Dilip Kumar in Apple in Amazon's pricing
and promotions division and Kumar spends
a couple of years under Bezos as his
technical adviser meaning that he's
shadowing Bezos all businesses meetings
and learning how to do the Amazon
culture pretty well and in sort of how I
am how does Amazon work inside what is
what business is it does it excel at
typically when after someone finishes
that so you move some pricing promotions
to a technical advisor advisor job
typically when someone finishes that
they can take a big swing and when he
finishes with Bezos as this technical
adviser pricing and promotions is almost
all automated so it's not going to go
back and do that so he gets together
with a bunch of people from the retail
division and says we need to figure out
a way to solve the most annoying part of
hopping in real life with technology and
they decided the most annoying part of
shopping in real life is checkout people
don't like waiting on lines and you know
scanning and all that stuff takes a lot
of time they just rather pick their
items and get the hell out so I started
thinking okay maybe we're gonna do a big
vending machine but they're like okay
that kind of kicks the can down the curb
so they say instead what if we use
computer vision and sensors and created
a store where people could just scan it
with a QR code take whatever they want
off the shelves and then leave and that
is what became Amazon's go store which
exists now in a bunch of cities is still
kind of experimental but I've used it in
San Francisco and Seattle and what I've
tried oh it feels like you're
shoplifting it's I'm bored you take the
stuff and you're like I'm out I'm free I
just got like nine Clif bars on the
house thanks Bezos and then two minutes
later they're like nine Clif bars dear
here's your receipt Tommy and you're
like you know it's really this wild just
wild experience and Amazon if you read
between the lines of Jeff Bezos whose
annual shareholder letters like they're
going to make this a more prominent part
of their retail operation and so because
so it's just all the parts coming
together right it's like you they've
taken the technology minimized execution
work made room for idea work build a
system to get ideas from people to
decision makers and when that system
works as well as it does you get another
new invention from Amazon which is go
and this is sort of how they've been
able to do so many different things from
like a first party marketplace to a
third party marketplace to of logistics
and fulfillment senator sorry logistics
in fulfillment operation to a cloud
services division to a voice computing
platform and a hardware manufacturer
that does things like the Kindle and all
of their speakers and then not to
mention an Academy Award winning movie
studio and a grocer all this is a it's
yeah this is a product of culture and
that's people think you know there's
this beat when you don't see inside
there's this vision oh Bezos is the guy
doing this he presses a button and
that's how it happens actually what he's
done is built the culture to harness
other people's ingenuity and bring it to
decision makers and that's how Amazon's
been able to be so inventive it's no
surprise
they're so dominant man like apps how
can you how are you supposed to compete
with that it's a company who has the
most innovation the most resources to
bring that innovation to market so even
if you have the idea they can probably
execute the same idea as you've had but
quicker and better and deploy it more
through a wider geographic range and all
the rest of it you mentioned about Jeff
Bezos and PowerPoint he banned
PowerPoint by sending an email with just
a subject line and it just said like no
more PowerPoint presentations allowed in
meetings or something yeah
I'd never heard of uipath before can you
tell us what you uipath is please yeah
it's an automation company so a lot of
times people say well the tech giants
are doing this so I could never do it
but it's really not the case and we
talked about minimizing execution work
making room for idea work there are
off-the-shelf solutions that any company
can use so in the introduction of the
book I talked about this company called
uipath and what uipath does its software
will watch your screen as you work so
you sort of open up a session and let's
say you're like filling out a form it
can watch your screen as you work and
each button you click and each you know
keystroke you make you just label it to
the to the machine learning system and
it will remember how to do it on its own
and so it can do it can fill out forms
it can send letters it can move data
from one spreadsheet to another it can
take over all this execution work that
we do all day long and you know take it
over via automation so I went to this
conference in Miami and it was crazy and
Cee Lo Green was the opening singer
which was hilarious he's going to the
audience all right if you got someone
you need to say [ __ ] you do now is the
time and they're like [ __ ] you and I'm
like you guys are like automating
people's jobs like is that it's kind of
weird but but and it was amazing to see
how many people how many different
industries were represented at this
conference let alone the stuff that it
can do but it was like you saw
automotive you saw insurance you saw
health you saw technology companies
there you saw banks and you know one of
the things that I was striking to me was
that
this technology is available to people
clearly there's interest inside
companies to put it into place but it's
almost as if they're like driving blind
they're like yeah we want to automate
but I heard very little about the
broader strategy of why to automate so I
do think that like if they're able to do
this and put some of the lessons from
the tech giants in place then they'll be
in much better shape didn't you say that
it's able to do hiring it can sort
hiring people and then when it comes
time to get rid of them as well that
this uipath thing can send them their
letter yes I know it's wild but it's
able to write letters so if you you know
new hire letters are pretty formulaic so
when you have a new hire letter your
iPad can handle that so of course you
can have a termination letter that it
can do as well it's just something about
it and so upon kind of seeing this big
overview obviously we've touched on
Amazon but there's Google Microsoft and
Apple and stuff as well and it sounds
dumb but I I kind of presumed that these
big companies just operate the same way
you know like when you get to the sort
of size of these companies you'll have
optimized everything and the size of the
operation will have whittled away any
ability to actually enact real change
cultural or operational and you just
kind of they were all they were all
going to be super homogeneous but again
upon reading and having a look at the
different ways that companies are deploy
now the end results still the same which
is we need to be able to innovate
quickly we need to have like a lack of
friction from idea to deployment and we
need to keep resources in blah blah blah
and look cool and wear hoodies but these
are important hoodies are very very
important um you know I mean like I was
surprised I would have thought it would
have been much more homogeneous that's
right yeah so I would say and always do
when I talk about how each one of these
companies has has their own flavor to
build it putting these systems into
place so we talked about Amazon it's the
six page or it's the use of machine
learning inside Facebook it's a feedback
culture which is something that a lot of
people might be surprised by you know
Facebook isn't exactly the company that
you think is one that takes feedback
very well given that people from the
outside I've protested almost every
product decision that
I've made and they've said basically at
like eff off like I'm gonna do this on
our own
yes exactly but inside the company there
is this feedback culture and in the book
actually sit in on a day-long feedback
training where people inside Facebook
are taught to give and receive feedback
major meetings end with requests for it
there are posters around Facebook's
Menlo Park offices that say feedback is
a gift and actually the first time I met
Zuckerberg I was surprised because
typically your your typical CEO briefing
is the CEO will tell you okay sit down
here's 25 minutes of me selling our new
product then the PR person will sort of
watch your facial expressions maybe
allow you to ask one question oftentimes
just say okay and that's not what it's
like being a tech reported with the big
duds right yeah that's usually what it's
like but with Zuckerberg it was totally
different because we walked in there and
he's like I want your feedback on this
like oh okay yes he has more interested
yeah he's he more interested in
listening to what was going on than
selling and that's when I started asking
people in Facebook's orbit what's going
on and that's how I learned that there's
this feedback culture inside Facebook
where people are encouraged to bring
ideas not only the air boss put to their
skip level manager and all the way up to
Zuckerberg himself and so feedback a lot
of people's people say feedback is about
putting people in their place letting
them know what's going to happen before
the review right so they're not
surprised when they sit in there and you
get like a meets or you know you're not
meeting your expectations okay you
should know I think that's totally wrong
way to look at feedback you mean it's
good to not have your people surprised
but what feedback functions for inside
Facebook is that it makes sure that
people feel comfortable sharing ideas
with anybody inside the company and then
people inside the company feel
comfortable receiving other ideas and
when Facebook has been told hey from
people inside actually we're not
approaching this right it has shown an
ability to change and shift direction
and that's why it's gone from an online
directory to a broadcast platform that
operates largely on desktop to a mobile
app that's still in doing this sort of
broadcast to all your friends and now
it's changing again moving to more
intimate networks like groups and
messaging so this is all because of
feedback these aren't Zuckerberg
brilliant ideas on his own it's and if
people when they read the book they'll
see it's other people inside the
organization
pulling him aside and being like hey
mark we're missing this important thing
we got to make a change and when he's
listened it's actually worked out pretty
well for them the CEO is a made to look
like just these bottomless pits of
innovation aren't they but it's actually
the it's the coalition of everything
that's happened below that so before we
got on acoustic companies I want to see
if you can if you can do this I want to
see if you can try and personify each of
the companies that you looked at into a
character so for instance I think Amazon
would be kind of the jock in school
super clean-cut dates the prom queen
Apple might be like the arty philosophy
student who all the girls fancy but he
keeps himself to himself and spends
lunchtime sketching trees how would you
sort of personifies some of the
companies that you looked at yeah Amazon
would be the MBA that's brilliant
but doesn't have very much empathy for
other people yeah yeah on the spectrum
somewhere yeah let's put him there yeah
so Facebook who Facebook is is almost
like the the kid in high school that
everyone thought was perfect you know
that was good at sports and good at
talking to people and you know was
attractive but also sort of missed part
of what living is all about because
everything was so easy for them yeah
yeah no challenge yeah no challenge yes
so that's kind of what I think Google
might be Google's just your classic nerd
nerd with a half sleeve tattoo that's
right nerdy kid and you're like oh okay
but not like you know a nerd you feel
bad about just say yeah you know that
you know okay this person's going to be
very successful
Apple Apple is like one of those high
society people that you know speaks
their own language and you know feels
very comfortable around people like them
but most of us but when they try to get
out to most of society they can't really
relate yea Microsoft okay and the
Microsoft is someone who's had a glow up
you know they were like an ugly
and they became the hottest person that
you know that's name so you've nailed
even they'll Microsoft that I absolutely
agree yeah so yeah we've talked about
Amazon we've talked about the feedback
and stuff in in in Facebook what
characterized Microsoft feed when
Microsoft is this amazing case study
because they were in this day to
mentality under Steve Ballmer of their
former CEO and back in the day all they
cared about was Windows their desktop
operating system and in the age where we
were not doing any computing on the
browser and using desktop computers
instead of mobile phones they were the
king right and they knew it and Congress
knew it and they ended up you know
bringing antitrust action against them
and then everything shifted and this is
sort of why time is generally more
potent than government regulation or you
know your competitors because Microsoft
could sit on this on this desktop
operating system for as long as it
wanted but the world changed and we
started doing computing on the browser
and we started using our phones instead
of our desktops and then what uses
windows much more I mean it is exactly
how Bezos described that day one day two
mentality right stasis yes irrelevance
uh you know slow painful decline check
ok death it was heading that way until
they had to change their their course
and so after Ballmer a guy named Satya
Nadella came in and took over and became
the CEO and Satya had been a 20-year
veteran of Microsoft and worked on [ __ ]
which is kind of funny everyone makes
fun of Bing like oh that's just the
shitty search engine special needs
version of God I wouldn't go that far
but somewhere in that range and so the
so the thing with with Bing is that it's
a cloud computing system and because it
works on it's a powerful program that
works on the internet that has to make
sense of all of these different links
coming in and and spit something out to
people that work so because I had worked
on that he had been able to see where
the future of computing was going
basically saying we're not going to work
on programs that we install I come in
the mail and we install in our computers
anymore
you know put it on Windows we're gonna
be working on our browser and that's
cloud computing and there's gonna need
to be an infrastructure that's going to
support cloud computing and the funny
thing about that is when you enable
cloud computing you actually hasten
windows decline because if you can
access a program on the browser you can
use it on a Windows machine or an Apple
machine or a Chromebook and you don't
really need Microsoft anymore or at
least in the Windows component so it's
actually a pretty gutsy move to say
we're gonna go support cloud first and
the other thing he says is we're gonna
make sure that our services are
available everywhere so Microsoft Office
you know used to only really be able to
get on a Windows machine you couldn't
really get on the Internet and that
ended and they made an app for the
iPhone which is sort of unbelievable
given Microsoft's history you know back
in the Ballmer days you weren't even
allowed to or yet you're basically not
allowed to have an iPhone or an Apple
product inside oh yeah totally people
like wood to get scorn and Ballmer even
pretended to smash an iPhone when he saw
it in a meeting so it was like we gotta
move past this so what he did was he
reorient to this company which wasn't a
day to mentality brought it to day one
and then once he figured out we're gonna
that company was going to structure it
self in a way that supports cloud
collaboration the internet then the
tough job
started which was to change Microsoft's
culture which had been you know
alpha-male our largest having loudest
person in the room yell at each other to
a culture where they had to start using
technology and again I'm gonna sound
like a broken record was really what
happened minimizing execution work
making room for idea work tailing ideas
to decision-makers and that's how
Microsoft turned it around and it's now
the most valuable tech company again
example have they really turned it
around because to me as someone who
doesn't really know I'm not watching
this share price I don't know what's
going on who's got what amount of market
and this any other but to me Microsoft
still out now feels like just the
grandad at the party type thing this
sort of older guy who used to kind of
maybe have it but now he's playing
second strengths these are the companies
but it sounds like the work that the new
CEOs Dunn's actually given them a
resurgence that's right yeah they're the
most valuable of all the five big tech
companies why which is because I do
think that investors see the value in
what they're doing which is moving
towards the future so the products that
they work on or not as sexy like cloud
computing back-end it's not a sexy as an
iPhone but it has you know a very bright
future and you look at now like we're
all sitting at home right now and
Microsoft's collaboration technology
with things like teams the usage is
going through the roof so they are
really moving to where the enter Blake
where I mean they're definitely b2b
enterprise technology but they're
crushing it there and there's a bright
future for them
I mean businesses have far more money to
spend and consumers do on these sort of
high high ticket
low volume kind of apps and services I
suppose but yeah that's interested that
it's interesting that um that one person
obviously will have brought the CEO will
have brought a team with him and other
people have had to have get on board to
deploy his ideas but the business the
size of Microsoft's can be changed by
the fundamental ideas and the vision of
just some bloke he's just some guy you
know he's a very capable guy obviously
who understands what he's talking about
but he's just some fella that's gone
like I think we should try and do this
and then the entire shape and diarrhea
of a company changes it's so mad yeah it
is amazing and by the way it's sort of
that that characterization sort of
underscores how difficult it is to do
what he did because it is one person
that's pushing this change and it's like
pretty remarkable that he was able to do
it most people that try end up failing
but he was able to make it happen
yeah ok Google let's talk to us about
Google what was Google's signature
special move they're they're special
move like you feel like this is like
they're like that
Mortal Kombat character that can go
across the screen you know shoot across
yeah yeah yeah yeah I know you mean
because they're you know Facebook if
ideas go up and down from the bottom to
Zuckerberg inside Google ideas go side
to side
you know across divisions very well and
that's because Google's interconnected
in the series of there
own social networks they have email
listservs that span the whole company
they have their own meme board like
almost like a reddit or an imager where
people make memes about the company and
vote them up and vote them down they
have Q&A is where people can ask the
leadership any questions they want
although that's been pared back a little
bit and most importantly they work in an
open drive meaning they use get Google
Docs slides and sheets and the sharing
on almost all those Doc's is set to open
so anybody in the company can go look
into anyone else's documents and at
first you know people say that's kind of
weird
but what it does is it allows people to
get caught up to speed on projects
incredibly fast and they can you know
when you're in a Google Doc you can also
add your ideas and comments and people
do that right so just like the 6 pager
got ideas to basil's quickly and the
feedback culture gets ideas to
Zuckerberg quickly ideas inside Google
can move side to side incredibly fast
and the example to show how this has
worked really well is the Google
assistant right which is their voice
assistant and the Google assistant
combines so many different products it
combines search and Android and mail and
calendar and maps and YouTube and in
order to build an effective assistant
you need everybody working together
otherwise you know it's gonna be pretty
dysfunctional and people won't use it
and people don't have a lot of patience
for a voice assistant like if you say
hey Google enough and it doesn't respond
you're not gonna keep saying it you just
type this [ __ ] in so you know so because
they were able to collaborate they're
able to build this pretty effective
assistant and and the assistant again is
this evolution of search it's another
reinvention right because when you speak
with a voice assistant you say what's
the weather gonna be right how would you
find that otherwise type it into search
you say where's my package coming how
would you find that out type it into
search or type it into Gmail so if
Amazon was able to get the lead because
got a mute er because you know Alexa
started answering those questions
instead of Google Google's domination
search was really would really be
challenged but because Google was able
to reinvent this way through
collaboration now it has a real foothold
in the voice assistant space and is able
to hold its own in its most important
product
is that going to be is the voice
assistance space gonna be as big as some
of my friends think it is because I've
got a couple of buddies who are addicted
to Siri
like absolutely adding they won't do
anything they refuse to touch their
phones to me other than controlling
music and stuff on I'm listening to it I
tend to not use it that much but moving
forward can you see voice assist is it
the next big thing one of the next big
things I think it very well could be and
the reason why I say that is because
we're still at like the pretty early
moments of artificial intelligence
technology and what we're doing by
talking to these things is training them
and every conversation they have helps
them get a little bit better so I think
that it's amazing there's already tens
of millions of these things in people's
homes and as that grows they'll get
better at figuring out what we want from
them they'll get better at talking back
to us like I even see that the Alexa
starts to get more conversational with
time like I say set an alarm and she
goes all right I'm setting your alarm
for 8:00 a.m. tomorrow you want me to
set that for every day this week and I'm
like how the hell did you know that
right so I do think yeah this is gonna
be big it will be big and they'll also
start plugging in with other people's
products and you know I I can I have an
idea why your friends like series so
much right because we're I mean
especially now we're all in our screens
all that you know all this time we're
tapping or look you're watching and it's
like you know if we can do any computing
by not having to deal with the screen
some people love that and I think
especially as that gets better you know
people will really embrace it
so I'm bullish on it nice bullish that's
it Alex contro it's bullish on on voice
voice commands I love it um that's an
interesting point about how voice
control or other non-physical versions
of input will affect our tech use you
know because if you can do a ton of the
things on your phone let's say it's a
hundred years further on and we're able
to we've got microchips that can detect
the correct neurons that are firing in
our brain and we can just control stuff
with our brains oh we got some sort of
wearable or whatever it is the line
between screen time and not
meantime could either diverge or could
completely come together so that either
there's barely any screen time or the
all-time history time you know I mean
yeah definitely
yeah I would bet that we're heading
towards a world where almost all time
and screen time but the cool thing about
voices that enables screen time to not
be screen time right like you can be
plugged in but it can be ambient sort of
in the background to grace' something
requiring your full attention
that's a brilliant way to put it I never
thought of it like that but it is it's
part of the environment when you use hey
Siri or okay hey Siri hey Google ok
Google ok Google hey Google I think both
work and then what's yeah Amazon what's
just like so on it's just a list Alexa
imagine if someone's kids being called
Alexa one night man I know man I'm Alex
I'm Chris you don't use any of these
voice assistance at all no really
so you so use Siri for controlling music
and podcasts and stuff like that I know
there's tons of things I can do with it
but I don't know I don't know and this
is someone who's trying to down regulate
his screen time and you know he's into
new tips and tricks and things like that
but it's just not like I feel like
trying to do it will end up creating
more work than if I just put it in
myself and like hey Siri direct me home
using this like this route and then it
will open up Google Maps instead of
Apple maps or Apple Maps inside Google
Maps or something
so I think maybe maybe this just a
another you know 10 or 20 percent of
progress that needs to be made and then
I'll probably just be all over it and
I'll just be talking talking to my phone
all all across the day yeah and it's
probably because you're talking a Syria
that is why you're frustrated the other
two are much better are they interesting
so I had young Stephen Wolfram on mm-hmm
you know Stephen go create I know I'm
language well from Wolfram Mathematica
and I'm talking to him about like those
answer engines and the ways that the
people that don't know Stephen Wolfram
is his company is the company that
created the answer engine that's able to
take words that you say convert that
into code and then re give you back
whatever the answer is
she super-complex to take the noise that
comes out of your mouth work out what
you meant turn that into something the
computer or the phone can read and then
give it back out and um the fact that
even we take it so much for granted man
but the fact that you can just make a
sound with your face and then your phone
does a thing is like totally
unbelievable it's and the fact that
innovation just continues to pump away
you know and then you've got oh well a
couple of like 10 years ago maybe you'd
watch like some 3d film with like you
know crap like red and blue things and
cardboard things you used to get over
your face you'd be like wow this is
amazing you'd be at Disneyland and then
now you've got like an oculus gol
headset all in one no extra stuff
required you just slip this thing on and
now you're in like Jurassic Park
fighting dinosaurs and study it it's
wild man I spoke to a lady as well who
has the world's first PhD in immersive
storytelling so this is like
cutting-edge VR stuff and she
recommended that I go to Jeff Wayne's
War of the Worlds immersive VR
experience down in London and I went to
go into it dude it is the wildest thing
I have crazy Oh like combination of VR
AR holographics
and real-life actors dude it was just
like the craziest two hours ever you
just feel like I don't know I don't know
what the entertainment industry is gonna
be like in sort of 30 or 40 years time
when that sort of stuff gets scaled out
but you're not even gonna watch movies
anymore you'll be living movies and then
oh I'm into it I'm ready for that
alright so good and then you go back and
you're like I'll watch a YouTube video
of a trailer and you realize just how
much less impact that has so yeah like
when your iPhone is able to throw smells
at you and stuff like that that's when
we're gonna be that's what we're gonna
be killing it so okay Apple my favorite
one out of the lot everybody here is in
the air fun what's going on with Apple
tell us well I'm sorry to disappoint
your listeners but a company with a
culture that needs a transformation why
and I think that's because an inside
Apple they've been very
good eye I call it a culture of
refinement they've been very good at
refining the iPhone which is their
flagship product right and they do that
by keeping people in silos and keeping
everything secret and what that does it
allows people to concentrate on their
one task so the people that make the
battery life live longer that's what
they're focused on the people that make
the screen better that's what they're
focused on the people that make the
iPhone thinner that's what they're
focused on the computing power that's
what they're focused on and they don't
spend a lot of time distracted speaking
to other people and that's helped make
the iPhone the best phone on the market
I don't think there's any doubt about
that I have one but for Apple it's made
it difficult for the company to reinvent
itself and I think we can go back to the
voice assistant example and and while
your friends might be using Siri only be
using Siri as the only way they use
their phones they're probably the only
two people on the planet to do that
because Siri is terrible and the reason
why Syria is terrible is because it was
thought about us not as a voice platform
but as a feature on the iPhone so just
sort of like this fun thing that like a
fun magical assistant you could talk to
not something that could connect you via
your voice to the rest of the internet
and because of that Apple said okay well
Siri folks why don't you sit in your own
room and that's not how it works like we
talked about the Google assistant Google
needed you know people across search and
Android and YouTube and maps and
calendar all these different divisions
and yeah and music to be able to
integrate with each other and be able to
talk to each other to be able to build
this thing without any barriers at all
and inside Apple these silos have
prevented the assistant folks from
actually getting out there in a way that
would be meaningful and helping Siri you
know become something that can overtake
the Google assistant and the echo and
the one the one example that I give is
that you know the the Google I mean
Apple gave Amazon a multi-year head
start it gave Google like a five year
head start on Google assistant like Siri
came out in 2012 these other things came
out in 2016 2017 2018 and then Apple
said ok finally they're gonna build a
speaker to put Syria inside of great so
they build the home pod the home pod is
not selling at all
so total odd and the echo and Google
home are in tens of millions of homes
and it's again it's funny because like
for Apple apples so interested in design
right so they think about the they think
about the sound of the speaker and the
look of the speaker and the feel of the
speaker whereas the echo is the ugliest
appliance I have my whole life it's
disgusting to look at it looking at it
now and I want to throw it out the
window but it's not about the speaker
the way it looks it's about the
assistant inside and so that's something
that Apple's gonna have to change
because it's not gonna be a visual or
physical design first it's going to be
computer design and that requires
collaboration and it's struck out on the
home pod it's also struck out I mean
yeah I think it's fair to say it's
really struggled to build its own car
it's trying to build a self-driving car
and the way they think about this yeah
yeah the way they think about this is
sort of like the iPhone right the iPhone
had beautiful hardware great software
put it together best phone on the market
card self-driving car similar right
beautiful hardware the that the way that
it looks and then bugh and then you know
a functional software which is the
self-driving software then Apple should
have the elite on the market there but
it's had put this old iPhone style
mentality into into building this car so
they don't let the machine-learning
engineers talk to each other that are
working on different projects so you'd
have people working on the car people
working on face ID one of them is
locating like lanes and markers and
stuff like that the other one is
locating facial features and it's been
difficult for them to talk to each other
which means their technology develops
slower but also there's been the
influence of design right so design
inside Apple is that is the most
important division first they figure out
how it's gonna look then they figure out
what's going on inside so engineering
some things slightly yeah yeah well it's
where it's worked very well for a lot of
products but for the car just hasn't
worked well because and I spoke with
some people who had worked on is the
design team asked them to take the
sensors that are out there to figure out
what's going on on the road and embed
them in the car because typically with
the saw driving car it looks like this
horrific you know rolling submarine with
all these different you
nobs and and I'll audition that was
round and yeah it looks almost as bad as
the echo and of course Apple isn't going
to be done with that so they said okay
take the sensors put it in the car so it
looks much nicer but for the machine
learning engineers it's much more
difficult to figure out what they're
trying to do because it's by putting
blinders on your eyes right now you can
only see this you know this much and
your peripheral vision is cut in a
certain way and then how do you make a
machine learn how to do self driving if
it can't get the full range of vision
and so that's one of the reasons why the
product just struggled I so look yeah
sorry I'm sorry go ahead I just think
that my seduction into Apple is probably
very common amongst like just normal
consumers you know you think all of
their products are super slick I'm
speaking to you on a MacBook Pro that I
upgraded to even though I didn't need to
just because a new one looked good got
an iPhone I've got air pods I bought my
mum and dads air pods for like last
Christmas and the Christmas before and
blah blah you know like but because the
design is so seductive and so visceral
and so easy to see right you know like
Microsoft perfect example like I do not
think sexy when I think Microsoft but
yeah money talks
you know the numbers don't lie and
they're the biggest the biggest company
of all the ones that we've spoken about
and they're doing like some of the least
sexy [ __ ] but I guess it all depends on
what the vision is near the other thing
is well that I've noticed when you're
talking about Apple is it seems like a
very old style approach to management
and also careers within a company in
that you've got specialization you know
this is Henry Ford [ __ ] you know this is
like 1910 [ __ ] the guy that that turns
the knob he's the knob Turner and the
guy pulls the lever he's the lever
puller and the did you know I mean and
it seems like that siloing could go one
of two ways but given the fact that all
of your competitors are being super
effective with this super transparent
free flow of information
it seems surprising the amazon have done
that do you think that they're gonna
be forced to make a change I'll start
really losing losing ground yeah and I
do think that this sort of goes to show
how difficult it is for a lot of
companies to get away from the factory
mentality right and apples definitely
still in it like Ford is a good example
specialization right like that's what
happens inside the company so I think
apples gonna be okay and I think that
like the things that you're talking
about like I'm also I have an iPhone I
have air pods I'm talking to you through
an Apple computer so I do think that
they're gonna be doing fine but to go
back to where we were in the beginning
of the conversation if the average
company on the fortune 500 last for 15
years now instead of 67 that means
there's gonna be shifts that will come
along that they won't be prepared for
unless they're ready to adapt and to me
the main question is is Apple gonna be
ready to adapt when those chips come for
it like maybe it is for his computing
maybe it's some other shift that we're
not aware of and are they gonna lose
their lead because of that and I think
it's quite possible so I do still have
hope that there will be culture change
there and they'll be able I think they'd
be as effective as they are today even
if they opened up a bit and yeah I think
that they if there's not a culture
change they'll be they'll still make
good phones but they'll struggle to
navigate the the next change so they're
kind of be like Microsoft if Microsoft's
stuck with Windows and didn't get into
new businesses yeah I get it
look Alex money it's been really really
awesome finishing up final question what
is your vision for tech or what your
predictions for the big things happening
in tech over the next five to ten years
what should we be on the lookout for I
mean I would say be on the lookout so
right now we've had like tech change our
consumer lives in a big way meaning that
like we're now we use Netflix to watch
TV to watch TV and movies and we all
have phones and apps and it's really
changed our experience living life
outside of the office and it's funny
because in the office it feels like
we're still living in the 1990s
sometimes given like the programs that
we use so I my first big prediction is
that we're gonna start to see technology
change our work lives in the same way
that it changed our consumer lives and I
think work is always a little bit
to adapt and I think that that's really
gonna make a difference for in terms of
the way that we work so I would look out
for that
I think AI is gonna be way more advanced
and change the way that we live in ways
that I'm not even sure how to predict
like one thing I've thought about the
guy Alex it has to be you if it's not
you who's it gonna be yeah well I guess
like it sort of goes to the point of the
book right they can't be just one person
with the vision it's everybody's ideas
that come together that actually you
know push forward to change but it's
gonna have happen in so many different
industries you know my dad is a
podiatrist and so in the US when when
your doctor you spend you know some of
your time working with patients and
almost all of your time filling out
charts and my dad every time I come home
he's just filling out charts I'm like
dad do you do anything else but fill out
charts he's like nope so I mean it'll be
amazing when we start to see this
technology start to gain you know if the
if if you iPad technology can write an
HR letter all right why can't there be
other technology that starts filling out
the paperwork for doctors I mean of
course you'd have to have it at a pretty
high you know specification and have to
you know understand privacy but a lot of
this stuff is is just like you know
write down and spit back it's not so
complex it's just you have to key it
into all these different systems so
there needs to be technology to be able
to do that that might change the medical
field because instead of having doctors
spend their time doing paperwork you
might actually have doctors spending
their time taking care of patients and
wouldn't that be cool so and I think
you've changed government as well I
expect us to see if we have the
political will to see leaner more
effective governments you know our
governments are the ultimate groups
bloated groups I mean talk about
execution work all the government does
the executioner imagine those people had
some time to come up with ideas to
figure out problems like climate and
poverty and health that would be amazing
well the fact is a virus within a
government you have to use the word
think-tank you know in that that's right
to think
tanga is the exception because everybody
else actually right is busy doing the
ops
that's exactly right Chris and that's a
freaking big problem so we need to work
to solve that hey it looks like
good handle on what we're talking about
Alex your link the link to your book
will be in the show notes below always
day one highly recommended where can
people go to check out your stuff online
yeah I appreciate it Chris so you can um
yeah they check the show notes for the
book also Google always day one and read
some of the reviews I think people have
been happy with it so far and then if
you want to connect with me i'm a pretty
online person you could just type my
last name into twitter kan TR o wi TZ my
DMS are open and I check my mentioned so
I'd love to hear from you they're
amazing everything that we've spoken
about will be linked in the show notes
below you already know what to do if you
enjoyed the episode go and give a like
to follow let him know what you think
dude I really enjoyed that I'm looking
forward to seeing what the next few
years is going store now I'm excited
thank you yeah me too it's gonna be a
while a few years that's for sure I hope
it becomes calmer and less trapped in
our houses than it is now let's see
we'll see dude thank you so much for
your time thank you Chris this is really
great
[Music]
you